it's an emotional time in my life for
sure sometimes a good day sometimes bad
days but overall it's been pretty
awesome Justin Bieber is making his
happiness and health a priority and he's
in a good place right now
a source tells ET that he's taking
everything day-by-day adding quote
Justin and Haley have been enjoying
traveling and relaxing and not doing too
many things that are stressful for
Justin just weeks ago Justin posted this
shot on Instagram revealing he had been
struggling a lot writing quote just
feeling super disconnected and weird I
always bounce back so I'm not worried
just wanted to reach out and ask for you
guys to pray for me if your core
foundation isn't supporting you then
you're just gonna you're just not gonna
be balanced you're not gonna have that
anchor to make sure you have a you know
I'm trying to say our source also says
that he and Haley still want to have a
more formal wedding but his health comes
first quote they still talk about
everything having to do with the wedding
they just aren't fully committed to
making it more concrete right now I'm
just learning more how to navigate
through situations better and how to
like just be myself but the pair did
take a big step they bought a new home
in Beverly Hills our source says they
wanted something safe centrally located
and that had room for their possible
expanding family adding Justin and Haley
really took their time to settle down
roots in LA because they wanted the
perfect home we have a good time
together he's just really sweet he's a
good kid it's a good part and
I love them
[Music]